[Music]
there are a lot of
perks to being an esports competitor you
get to travel the world
you make a living playing video games
and if you're especially popular you'll
have
legions of fans that will do anything
for your attention
jesus of course being in the spotlight
is all well and good
when things are going your way but this
is esports we're talking about
a competitive arena that can see heroes
turned into
villains with a single misclick of a
mouse
here we go here's right and as well it's
been going to try and keep them out
redemption down right
dive by giving higher gentlemen
[Applause]
fans will scrutinize you and discuss
your every move on
social media hell sometimes you'll even
get roasted
live on stream twenty thousand percent
tattoos
tactical is tilting me so
but what if all the attention that was
focused on a world famous player like
you
didn't always reach you and instead the
constant commentary on your performances
was
accidentally sent to someone who doesn't
even know who you are
or what game you play well in the case
of emily perkins
who just happens to be known as perks
that's exactly what happened my name is
emily perkins you might know me as the
other
perks because i was trying to get on
with my day i ended up retweeting
uh i don't know who you are but can you
untag me in this because
i don't know what you're all about so
how is it that an unfortunate case of
mistaken identity
resulted in a lovely lady from lester
being tangled up in the world of league
of legends how has she turned this
bizarre mix up into an
unlikely passion for the game and how
has her journey as
a noob with a famous name become one of
league's most
inspiring stories oh no it was a trap
[Music]
hey guys it's dimitri now having your
life
invaded by league of legends die hards
may not be easy
but you know what is switching to geico
15 minutes could save you 15 or
more on car insurance be sure to check
out the link in the description below
alright now back to business who exactly
is
emily perkins well the truth is she's
many things
she's a science teacher from leicester
england she's also
a loving wife and a proud mother who's
interested in fantasy literature
and crocheting and she's the proud owner
of three guinea pigs but until very
recently
emily perkins was not an avid fan of
esports
in fact she barely knew anything about
them i think i'd probably
heard the net like if you'd have asked
me before then of what's esports i'd
have probably said
it's computer game sport so i'd have
probably
heard of it in that context i've had no
idea
that it was stadium filling so i had no
idea of the scope and the scale of it
but while emily lived and taught in a
small
english city a croatian league of
legends player was making his name
as one of the greatest western forces
ever to touch the game such a close
exchange for now they're winning but
perks is coming in this is his hero
moment if he wants to turn this fight in
favor of team this could be the game he
gets the final moment
he's next on the list there's no way he
can do it yasuo ahmad is coming in but
he's just walking into the meat grinder
of perks
pawn can't do it it's not enough they've
done it
can he get it done he can't the vladimir
they can't do
it this is it the greatest team
in the history of league of legends
taken down
by the greatest team europe has ever
produced
now if you haven't been following league
for very long
luca perks perkovich is kind of a big
deal
he is an eight-time european champion an
msi champion
a world's finalist and two-time
semi-finalist
but on top of his obvious pedigree perks
is
also known for being a bit of a troll do
you
think maresh again you're probably
starting to feel living jitter and
watching it crash bird without you
but these two people from entirely
different worlds
and generations were unknowingly on an
unbelievable collision course because
while emily perkins is many things
she also happens to be known as perks
on twitter our story begins in january
earlier this year
when perks and his new team cloud9
took on a hundred thieves during the lcs
lock-in semi-finals and while discussing
the games
some twitter users didn't check the
perks handle
they were using they thought they were
getting one purse
when in reality they were getting
another
now this wasn't the first time that
emily had been mistaken for perks
but this time as the notifications
mounted
she finally decided that she'd had
enough i started to get a little bit
annoyed because i was trying to get on
with my day i ended up retweeting
uh i don't know who you are but can you
untag me in this because
i don't know what you're all about
emily's response caught the eye of
travis gafford
who quickly retweeted it drawing the eye
of more league fans who
tried explaining to her what was going
on a few days later
during the finals emily was sent a link
to i will dominates lcs
co-stream of the match between cloud9
and team liquid
and as the close series went to a game
five
even the casters couldn't ignore what
was happening it's important to
recognize those who stepped up
to get c9 on the precipice of another
reverse sweep and of course that's gotta
go to perks on twitter
and no i'm not talking about the c9
perks that you all know and love
i'm talking about perks who is by her
own description just some woman in
lester who got pulled into the hype
today
and once the community discovered that
emily had a guinea pig who happened to
share a name with one of perks's
teammates
the ridiculousness of the situation only
escalated
although c9 perks might have lost the
close series
for some people twitter perks stole the
show
the best thing about the whole series
was the emily perkins meme you know the
emily
this was the best thing ever kind of
series ever with her
guinea pigs they were guilty yeah and
then one was called fudge this was a
meme breaker
it was the best thing ever and as the
memes grew more and more ridiculous
emily began to have some fun with it
herself i've tried to position myself
as mama perks that's like my choice
i don't know if cloud9 liked that or not
but that's how i've
set myself up for the fans anyway in the
span of a few weeks emily had gone from
being a total
outsider to league of legends to one of
the most talked about personalities in
the scene
[Music]
oh boy fudge what a long day now with
some of the most famous people in the
lcs
fudge it wasn't long before mainstream
media outlets latched on to the story
bemused by the idea that a local woman
could have such an
impact on north american esports whether
she wanted it
or not emily's life had been invaded by
league of legends
they're eating her and then they're
going to eat me
oh my god but thanks to her positive
interactions with the community
she was inspired to dive head first into
learning about the game
there's hundreds of thousands millions
of people
watch this game so there must be
something about it
i downloaded it i opened it up
couldn't move so
i just closed it again because i didn't
understand what was happening i didn't
have a mouse i had a mouse pad didn't
know you needed a mouse so i do it so i
tried it again
and i had a mouse and i tried it again
but i'd been told off by
riot games for leaving a game i tweeted
that people thought that was hilarious
because i'd really know i'm really sorry
write games i didn't mean to i just
don't know what's happening
not long after figuring out how to get
the game working and avoiding the ire of
riot
emily began uploading her first games
versus bots
to youtube now initially emily found
herself drawn to rhythm
mostly because the champion's combos
reminded her of a game she was all too
familiar with
so i love computer games i've played
computer games all my life but mostly on
um like consoles so
i'm not scared of trying a new computer
game the thing is like
we always play tekken we used to do 10
hit combos
so doing a four key combo for me
didn't seem that difficult as emily grew
more comfortable with the game she began
to share her experiences playing
it and fans got a real kick out of her
interactions
with certain champions especially when
she first crossed paths
with yumi now if you don't know anything
about yumi
here is all you need to know her entire
stick is that she latches herself onto
other
champions in order to survive kind of
like
wisp in dota mercy in overwatch
or phase clan in competitive cs go to
put it into perspective
you can literally go to the toilet while
playing yumi
and your team might not even notice
seriously
i didn't quite get what was going on and
they sort of said i should report it
but because i didn't understand it i
thought well i'll ask my friends on
twitter
so uh i spoke to my friends on twitter i
posted it
and i was on about 6 000 followers at
this point
and within an hour i'd gone up another
thousand and a half followers so i very
innocently asked about whether i should
report this character or not
people then sort of explain what the
character does however i still think
that the person who was
sat on me wasn't doing what they should
have been doing
in spite of having only discovered
league of legends a few days prior
emily's innocent noobish exploits
really endeared her to the community why
because she was refreshing for a
decade-old scene that is so
used to every opinion being expert in
every play being textbook
emily tapped into the nostalgia other
league players had of discovering the
game for the first time
every single person played a game for
the first time once
every single person who's really good at
the game had to play it for the first
time and they had to be rubbish at it
so just because you're a noob which is
what it's called it doesn't matter
just play the game just enjoy it and
don't worry about being you
ask your questions to say hey i'm new to
this i'm really enjoying it but can you
help me with this on top of playing
league more and more
emily also invested more time into
watching her namesake
and cloud9 and soon enough she became
their number one super fan nervous when
they played and
joyous in their victories emily became
glued to the new team
she'd adopted but cloud9 weren't just
going to draw the line with
memes and twitter interactions no they
saw
huge potential in this dear sweet woman
from leicester
and on april 5th of 2021 they sent
waves through the world of league of
legends by announcing that they'd
signed perks again
they've set up several things to do so i
did the nines they also did their
interview
with me which over 300 000 people have
watched which is
crazy i also did um they set it up so
that their
academy coach could train me in how to
play so that was really fun
it's okay we got her nice good heel
cloud9 even had emily host their
tailgate show before their lcs spring
final versus team liquid
where she interviewed cloud9 ceo jacques
tien
hell she even did the most british thing
ever
she spent time teaching cloud9 fans
how to make english scones so there we
have it
we have our
tea and our scone
ready to go and eat but what about the
collab
that everyone wanted to see what about
perks
and perks well the two finally crossed
paths when emily hosted a series of 1v1s
between perks
and fudge where she was able to quiz her
doppelganger
on her favorite english food we've
missed the most important question
the most important question is do you
know what a toad in the hole is
no i don't know i just think he's
incredible
he's a young man who's moved halfway
across the world
to fit into a new team and he's
absolutely annihilating
his opponent i just think he's brilliant
now as much as the affection and
attention emily was receiving
overwhelmed her the truth is she never
got
caught up in the hype and more
importantly she
recognized that her newfound platform
could be used to benefit a motivation
close to her heart ever since the tragic
passing of one of her students in 2015
emily has been an active fundraiser for
the laura center which helps to support
grieving families but now with her
additional clout in the league community
and because of cloud9's play together
campaign emily's been able to help raise
further
funding for that cause and she's even
looking at combining her passions for
teaching
fundraising and esports into organizing
her own event
so in my family of schools um there are
three secondary schools
and i'd love to set up an esports
competition between the three schools
the three schools can play each other
that's what i want what i'd really love
to do for my
personal um joy and for my students and
my schools
is try and make that happen just a few
months ago
nobody in league of legends had ever
heard of emily perkins
now she reps one of the biggest orgs on
the planet
has thousands of followers and she even
has her own twitch channel
the um yes first blood
let's be honest it's been a tough year
for esports
an uncertain year the usual packed
stadiums and iconic events
have been sorely missed but
rediscovering esports through emily's
inexperienced eyes
all because of a simple coincidence has
been
one hell of a pick-me-up her
introduction to a world that she
previously didn't even know existed
might have been eye-opening for her but
if anything
for the league community she has been
the true revelation
and for emily that's just one of the
perks
of the job i'm in all my gear look i've
got my
top on i've got my top on here i've got
my trousers on i was like oh wonder if
anyone will recognize me
esports athlete always feels weird i
know people say that all the time but
kind of cringe i guess
well the truth is the truth is poor lady
i know it could have been any other game
right
it could have been a good game could
have been a good game but rip
rip